en europe on connaît la première
technique de la saison avec un mercure
qui devrait dépasser les 30 degrés dans
plusieurs régions et avoisiner les 40
degrés par endroits
à nantes c'est la ruée vers les piscines
ouvertes un peu plus tôt qu'à l'habitude
jusqu'à entre 800 et 1000 personnes sur
la journée donc c'est énorme par rapport
aux journées classique où il ya trois
nuages une influence qui rappelle que
l'accès à l'eau et à la fraîcheur
demeure bel et bien un enjeu de santé
publique des personnes âgées parlons
aussi des femmes enceintes et des
nourrissons parlons aussi des de la
santé au travail la prévention reste
donc de mise pour éviter de revivre les
effets de la canicule de 2003 qui avait
fait plus de quinze mille morts les
climatologues nous le disent et puis on
le voit concrètement ces vagues de
chaleur sont appelé à s'étendre dans la
saison
avant si on veut et quelques décennies
ça se passait en juillet et en août
principalement week-end
le secrétaire général des nations unies
lui déclare qu'il est encore possible
d'inverser la spirale de la sécheresse
associé au changement climatique
or la sécheresse et semble bien installé
en espagne depuis le moine et où on a
enregistré les températures les plus
élevées depuis les 100 dernières années
trois feux de forêt font rage dans la
région de la catalogne le plus
dévastateur d'entre eux auraient brûlé
entre 5000 et 7000 hectares au
nord-ouest
à brighton royaume-uni les anglais
s'apprête à vivre leur journée la plus
chaude de l'année pour certains il ya
quelque chose qui ne tourne pas rond
alors que pour d'autres ça reste aussi
l'occasion de relaxer un peu ici gabriel
prou à du canada montréal